dann springt er auch nicht mit dir
runter und haut einfach alle tot tschüss
Collie tschüss oh nein nein das war wohl
dann doch nicht laufen wieder
wir mussten
hallöchen meine lieben Freunde und
herzlich Willkommen zu 2 Girls one cup
zusammen
Minecraft yeah
ich wollte die Map sowieso schon spielen
weil ich habe nämlich ich bin ein
richtiger Super Smash Brothers Fan auf
der GameCube und auf der wie gewesen und
auf der Nintendo 64 okay zu erklären
jeder kann jetzt in der Klasse auswählen
wir gehen auf eine Meppen müssen alle
gegen 16 Uhr
einfach alles reingegangen bist
habe ich eine Villager Maske
ja
okay gut
okay
wir verlinken uns irgendwie unten in der
Beschreibung und dann können
alle außer mich nein außer umgespielt oh
okay irgendjemand war was denn
bei mir ja sowieso alles super bin ich
unsichtbar ja
unsichtbar gewesen
wo bist du nein nein nein ja ja noch so
ein Schweine Glück mit deinem scheiß
Zombie missgestalteten Charakter der
kann irgendwie alle so wegschubsen
du bist gestalten so jetzt bist du dran
nein richtig nicht in unserem nein nein
nein
ich hätte eine Eingeweide aus deinem
Körper rausreißen und sich damit an die
nächste Box ohne Witz
wo seid ihr ich musste gerade
bitte bitte okay du kommst zu mir
gerade los los los nein
nein nein
oh mein Gott oh mein Gott oh mein Gott
das ist hier ah nein
ungespielt hast so drauf ne
logisch sagst Mama okay
das war's für mich
ich glaube ich bin draußen habe ich noch
ein Leben ja komm ich habe bestimmt noch
Mutter leben oder draußen jawohl kann es
draußen
zum ersten Mal also grad haben
was machst du da Alter verloren
nein
die neuen Map von ja ich habe gefunden
oh mein Gott du hast gewonnen
okay
das war ganz kurz Stopp bevor wir unsere
Klasse auswählen lass mal ganz kurz hier
bleiben so machen wir kurz ein
Siegerehrung herzlichen Glückwunsch
hallo hallo hallo
wir sind in dem Raum drin bevor
absprechen
gar nicht also gerade ist bei mir rot
sonst hat er gar nichts
weil ihr seid in meinen Augen die
größten Dieter der Welt okay warte mal
die end okay
hättet auf mich warten sollen ich habe
gar nichts jetzt bin ich auf ihn
gewartet
irgendwas okay
dran
da läuft da der Kleine aus niedlich und
das kann
ich jetzt auf dich weißt du mein Freund
ich weiß nicht was hier abgeht für eine
Party ich weiß auch nicht abgeht
ja ja
richtig scheiße
kann gar nichts machen
bei der Farben Auswahl genau
tschüss
die muss man dann nehmen da kommen gute
Sachen rausnehmen
einfach alle runter
ich habe vorhin auch schon
diamantschwert gefunden voll Stolz und
so Unsichtbarkeit tschüss
scheiße dass ich dich nicht sehe ich
habe trotzdem
Unsichtbarkeit getrunken das ist
schleimiges Wort
ja den habe ich gespannt das ist ein
Pokéball
altertiert
ja ich mache sinnlose Sachen am Sport
Alter
ich werde gleich zum Andreas
mit zwei Leben und ich mit vier
Pokéball
ein bisschen interessanter machen nein
sehr interessant
ne ich bin ja wie am Spawn ja du hast
glaube ich gewonnen
ich weiß wie wir dich umbringen können
alle du hast die Map in die Luft
gesprengt echt ja wusste ich gar nicht
gesprengt ein paar Schwierigkeiten
machen
ja dann ja da haben wir ein paar
Hindernisse
jedenfallen
ich gehe mal runter wir haben kein
tntiges Platz
dann bei der nächsten Stunde
eine kleine Runde noch dann haben wir
ungefähr
ich gehe ins Blau diesmal so ich nehme
boah ich habe jetzt die beste Klasse
ich nehme so eine du hast jetzt auch ein
Creeper Kaktus okay wir nehmen diesmal
die Map ähm village
das sieht aus
ja
gar nicht gedacht
Leute
wenn jemand dann plötzlich wenig Leben
runter und haut einfach alle tot tschüss
oh nein nein das war wohl dann doch
nicht
nein
Mist okay
ich habe gar keine Tränke bekommen was
soll das denn für die Frechheit da muss
ich heute muss ich jetzt echt
woanderseln mal gucken was anbietet 19
Kohle wir können noch
warum bekomme ich kein ah jetzt bekomme
ich wieder welche jetzt kann ich wieder
so richtig abgeben wie eine Rakete
tauschen aber geht leider nicht ja
nein nein
nein oh mein Gott
warum werde ich von hinten angegriffen
nein verdammt ich war unsichtbar Junge
auf mich anzugreifen
ich will Hauptsache nur überleben ich
London Alter
und dass ihr mich nicht findet
sein Leben retten und dann will er uns
am Ende töten ihr wisst ja gar nicht wo
ich bin
oh hier kann man leider von hinten Junge
von hinten
aber ich kann hier nichts abbauen von
hinten von hinten von hinten nein
ich kenne doch nicht rum ich denke an
dich
hoch wenn du willst es geht nicht kaputt
Pokeball los
Greif an los mein Zombie Pokémon nein
ich bin tot
Luca zugeschlagen okay das kann auf den
Dächern komm ich bin Spider-Man
nein nein nein nein hallo
ich hasse mich wenn ich mich selbst
abwerfe
gewinnen Leute ich will diese Runde
gewinnen
unsichtbaren angegriffen also nicht
vielleicht weil keine Ahnung das ist
Luke place ah komm wir haben ja ich
glaube oder
nein
ich habe gewonnen ich bin blau ich bin
blau habe ich gewonnen noch
ich habe gewonnen
hey hey Leute
das war unsere erste Moment
noch
ungefähr
wenn es euch gefallen
hat keine Bewertung da bewertet extra
gar nicht genau
vielleicht vielleicht
ein bisschen strukturiert nicht mehr so
durcheinander aber dann würde ich sagen
ja bis zum nächsten Mal und ciao
was machen
Scheiße gespielt
soweit ich habe jetzt hier so ein blödes
Schwert ich werde das mit mir gar nichts
richtiges Schwert hast du ne
ich bin Enderman
tschüss
am schönsten ist was machst du junge was
willst du von mir
Alter
obwohl du gerade gar nicht aufnimmst ne
du zeigst dein Zuschauer wo ist ich bin
einfach nur für mich
drin
schneller
oder Wasser
gepostet
der Mikrofon hängt von verkehrt rum habe
ich geschrieben
ja gesehen kommen
Pack und das ist
im Netz
in die Kommentare schreiben ob euch
solche Sachen gefallen
oh mein Gott
nichts mehr irgendwie machen okay
ich habe ein Pokémon verstehen
so ungefähr 70% gewonnen ich war
eigentlich richtig gut ich habe voll
gewundert Prozent
irgendwie werde ich immer besser werden
so 20 Minuten Ruhe dann auf einmal
ja witzig ne Simon richtig witzig so
jetzt epic fight ah geworden
wenn es euch gefallen hat dürfte einen
Daumen Hoch gewinnt nicht dann lass es
einfach bei Kabel eh fick dich geh weg
kannst die Daumen runter hallo
weil genug auf auf neutral aber man kann
doch eh nicht mehr
okay stimmt ich kann mich jemand
zu werden
bis zum nächsten Mal tschüss